this is the story of how Disney finally
lost the copyright to Mickey Mouse well
not all of Mickey Mouse parts of Mickey
Mouse look it's it's complicated you
might recall that when AA mil's Winnie
the Pooh lost copyright protection in
2022 the slasher flick Winnie the Pooh
Blood and Honey soon followed and on
January 1st 2024 Tigger joined his bare
friend in the land of public domain and
a violent version of Tigger will appear
in the sequel to that movie but Tigger
and poar are not the only beloved
childhood characters who are getting a
makeover Make Way for Steamboat Mickey
she's a Carnage yes now that at least
the very first version of Mickey is part
of the public domain the internet has
definitely wasted no time in creating
ridiculous versions of Mickey Mouse so
the question is now that Steamboat
Willie is in the public domain what does
this mean for being able to use Mickey
in all kinds of other contexts well this
is a very very complicated subject but
it all dates back to the release of Walt
Disney's short cartoon Mickey Mouse in
Steamboat Willie in 1928 which was a
major milestone in the rise of takis and
the development of Animation featuring
an early version of Mickey Mouse this
version of the Mickey Mouse character
entered the public domain on January 1st
2024 now as a young illustrator Walt
Disney had an early brush with copyright
law that changed the way that he
approached business working with fellow
animator u i Works Disney created Oswell
the Lucky Rabbit who starred in 26 short
films in the 1920s at the time Disney
and I Works worked for Universal which
meant the company owned the copyright to
Oswald when Disney asked Universal to
increase his rate by $250 per short the
company secretly signed Disney's
animators and removed him as their boss
the company then offered Disney $500
less per short unfortunately for Walt
Disney he didn't have the option of
joining a Creator owned platform like
nebula where storytellers have creative
freedom so Disney turned down the offer
and lost all rights to the Oswald
character Oswald did not return to
Disney until 2006 when NBC Universal
traded him back to ABC Disney in
exchange for sportscaster Al Michaels I
didn't even know that Al Michaels was
animated that explains how he's had such
longevity now there was some question
about whether Universal actually still
had the Oswald copyright since they may
have forgotten to renew it but but
neither company has let this
technicality get in the way of a good
story but back in the 1920s Disney vowed
to never lose control of his creative
works again after the Oswald Fiasco he
was almost broke and wound up living in
the studio where he often heard mice
scurrying around the building W started
leaving food out for the mice and
eventually befriended the bravest one
who became his pet Walt even let the
mouse live in a custommade suite inside
his desk drawer that humble Mouse wound
up inspiring the entire Disney Empire
when Disney after a particularly absent
heavy night heard the Mouse squeak keep
a firm grip on your intellectual
property and your riches will be as
numerous as the Stars we assume uh
Disney and U invented in animated Mouse
and put him in cartoons the first two
cartoons featuring Mickey Mouse bombed
but they were silent shorts and didn't
see wide distribution steo Willie was
the first cartoon to have a
post-produced soundtrack of dialogue and
synchronized sound effects with
orchestral music mirroring the action on
screen Mickey Mouse doesn't speak in the
film but the scene where he Pilots a
steamboat while whistling the song
Steamboat Bill represented a
breakthrough in animation the public was
amazed by Steamboat willly and it became
a sensation the 8-minute cartoon debuted
in front of a feature called gang war
that was expected to be a big hit gang
war turned out to be forgettable but
steo willly was such a hit that allowed
Disney to avoid bankruptcy hire
additional animators and experiment with
the techniques that would lead to the
Golden Age of Animation but even the
mighty Walt Disney Company is not immune
to the Copyright Act although as we'll
talk about it has certainly influenced
the development of American law in the
US the Copyright Act grants creators a
number of exclusive legal rights over
their original works of authorship
including literary dramatic musical
artistic and other int ual works the law
protects the owner of the work if other
parties copy present or display the work
without the owner's permission so if the
copyright work is an animated film like
Disney's Alice in Wonderland copyright
law protects the film in its entirety as
well as its titles characters music and
merchandise so that means that if you
sell a t-shirt with the image of Alice
or painted on a mural outside your
daycare you're going to get sued by
Disney because they own the copyright
for Alice and Wonderland yes it really
is a litigious world after
[Music]
all copyright expired the idea and it's
totally debatable is that if you give
authors a monopoly over the works that
they create they will be incentivized to
create more if they didn't have
protection they would be disinclined
from creating that kind of art but there
is a catch copyright owners don't have
control over their work forever all
copyrights eventually expire which means
the creative works are then owned by the
public the term the public domain refers
to creative materials that are not
protected by intellectual property laws
anyone can use a public domain work
without requesting permission from the
original author or the company that
owned the work and when a work is in the
public domain you don't even have to
change it into something new into a
derivative work you can use it and even
sell it in its original form though at
the same time you should know that
something being public and being in the
public domain are very very different
things just because something is public
the fact that you can Google something
on the Internet uh does not mean that
that thing is in the public domain in
fact it's probably not in the public
domain usually it takes a lot of time
for the copyright to expire for
something to no longer have a copyright
and to finally enter the public domain
and there are four ways that creative
Works usually arrive in the public
domain the copyright expires the
copyright owner fails to follow
copyright renewal formalities the
copyright owner donates the material to
the public or copyright law doesn't
protect a certain type of work like
facts basic math or recipes now since
most reasonable people agree that
artists should be paid for their work
why doesn't copyright last forever well
the idea behind public domain is that it
Fosters Innovation creativity and
knowledge it encourages artists to draw
on previous works of art to create
something new it makes it easier for
Publishers to publish lower cost
editions of important books it makes it
easier for teachers to distribute
educational materials and it helps
artists build on the art that existed
before obviously Walt Disney himself
made excellent use of the public domain
by taking popular fairy tales such as
Cinderella and Classics like aliceon
Wonderland and turning them into beloved
movies because those were in the public
domain at the time in fact even
Steamboat Willie made use of the public
domain the film used the song turkey and
the straw which was in the public domain
at the time of production and the title
steo will was a reference to Steamboat
Bill Jr a Buster Keaton movie that was
released that same year heck that
reference might be one of the first uses
of fair use parody in an animated movie
so Disney designed his movies to appeal
to audiences who were already familiar
with a popular work now Steamboat Willie
was unveiled as a Walt Disney Animation
Studio short on November 18th 1928 when
it was released the US copyright law
protected copyrights for 56 years but by
the time the copyright on Ste but
willing was due to expire in 1984 Disney
had become the biggest entertainment
company in the world and Mickey was one
of the most recognizable characters on
Earth so Disney as well as other
companies lobbied Congress to extend the
copyright term the result was the
Copyright Act of 1976 which increased
the renewal term for Works copyrighted
before 1978 that had not already entered
the public domain from 28 years to 47
years giving a total term of 75 years
Disney delayed Mickey's entry into the
public domain yet again in 1998 Disney
again with other companies lobbied so
hard for the 1998 Amendment to the law
that sometimes called the Mickey Mouse
protection act although the guy that
wrote it also had something to gain from
it as well the law is officially known
as The Sunny Bono copyright term
extension act and it extended the
copyright protection from 47 to 67 years
giving copyright holders 19 more years
uh that's Sunny Bono of sunny and Sher
who actually went on to become a
congressman so that meant the copyright
for steo willly was set to expire on
January 1st 2024 now for further
discussion of the expansion of the
various copyright acts a check out
Jake's video over at Corridor crew he is
also a lawyer and does a great job of
breaking down how the various Acts were
extended but this time around to the
surprise of many congress did not extend
the Copyright Act further delaying
Steamboat Willie and Mickey Mouse's
entry into the public domain but if you
thought Disney was just going to sit on
his hands you don't know the Disney
corporation uh Instead The company took
another path and instead it's now
relying on trademark law now obviously
Disney has really good lawyers but if
you want a great lawyer my firm the
eagle team can help if you've suffered
an injury or death in the family got in
a car crash or are dealing with a
workers comper social security issue we
can represent you or or help find you
the right attorney it's really important
to talk to a lawyer right away so you
can get the best representation and find
out what all of your options are so just
click on the link in the description for
free consultation with my team because
you don't just need a legal team you
need the eagle team so click on the link
below while copyright law protects
artistic works that are laid down in
some sort of tangible medium trademark
law protects a word phrase symbol or
design that's used by an entity to
identify its product or service the idea
is a trademark is for the good of
consumer to know where goods or services
come from they see a trademark or a
service Mark and they can identify who
is providing that service or good and
anticipating that they might lose its
copyright in Mickey Mouse Disney
Incorporated this image of Mickey at the
wheel of the steamship into its logo it
now runs before every animated feature
the company filed a trademark
application in 2022 describing the mark
As quote a motion Mark of an animator's
drawings visually flipping one after
another and transitioning into an
animated clip of a mouse character
tapping his foot and whistling while
holding a ship's wheel followed by the
appearance of the wording Walt Disney
Animation Studios underneath the
animated Mouse character now this might
be a smart move because trademarks do
not expire as long as you're actually
using them in Commerce there are
trade-offs in all IP copyright is
automatic as soon as you create the art
effectively you have a copyright whether
you registered or not uh trademarks
require you to actually use them in
service you can't register a trademark
and then never use it that won't protect
anything so here's where I think we are
Steamboat Willie the animated short is
in the public domain for sure you can
use that animated short and display it
uh as a
[Applause]
video but Steamboat willly slth original
version of Mickey Mouse might be a
trademark itself and it might be also a
copyrightable character you probably
can't use the public domain version of
Mickey in a way that makes consumers
think that the work is produced by or
sponsored by Disney uh the reason Disney
started incorporating sko Mickey into
its animated features was to create an
association between that version of the
character in the modern Disney audience
and it's an open question whether you
can even make a work of art featuring
The Steamboat Willie version of Mickey
Mouse that doesn't make you visualize
the popular Disney character as it
exists today believe me this is going to
make a fascinating test case for some
poor unfortunate soul but that's just
the tip of the legal Iceberg now nobody
really knows how this is going to play
out in court a lot will depend on
whether Disney becomes a trademark hawk
or decides to just let it go in theory
people can use the original image of
Steamboat Willie and aty today is filled
with products like this retro Disney
t-shirt or this cutting board however if
any of this threatens to dilute the
trademark Disney could use trademark law
to crack down and as you can see the
earliest iteration of Mickey had solid
black eyes and skinny arms and legs and
he didn't wear gloves or even speak he
had a longer tail of nose and he was
more of a trickster than the wholesome
piece of intellectual property that we
know today all the newer versions of
Mickey including the ones that you're
most familiar with which show Mickey
wearing red shorts and white gloves will
still be protected by existing
copyrights or will they what if someone
argued that all of the versions of
Mickey Mouse that Disney thinks are
protected by copyright law are actually
just derivative of that first original
steamboat Mickey and therefore you can
make a movie using the character traits
that appear in the later Mickey
appearances what would the courts think
well the answer lies in the way that
courts apply the originality requirement
of derivative works in the United States
an alteration to an original work is
called a derivative work and only the
copyright owner has the right to make or
authorize an adaptation of an original
for example the movie Jurassic Park is a
derivative of the novel Jurassic Park
and Steven Spielberg had to get
permission from Michael kryon to turn
the novel into the movie and a
derivative work is entitled to its own
separate copyright so long as the
additional material is more than a
simple editing change and contains
materials that are original to the work
so this raises two questions actually
this raises like a thousand questions
but I'm going to only talk about two of
them the first is can Disney somehow
extend its copyright over the Steamboat
Willie cartoon by tweaking the character
and the second is can someone make a
cartoon based on steamboat Mickey and
include aspects of modern Mickey well
all they'd have to do is argue that the
later changes are deriv ative of
Steamboat Willie and are therefore in
the public domain well this is not the
first time these questions have come up
and there has been similar litigation
thanks to the litigiousness of the
Arthur Conan Doyle estate I.E the estate
of the author that created Sherlock
Holmes now Sherlock Holmes has been
around since 1887 and at least 50
stories featuring Holmes and Watson have
been in the public domain but because
Arthur Conan Doyle was so prolific a lot
of these Sherlock Holmes stories
continued into the 1920s so there have
been many decades when some but not all
of the Sherlock Holmes stories have been
part of the public domain and that
raises the question what happens to the
characters contained in all of those
books when some of the books are in the
public domain and some are not and in
particular when lawyer and author Leslie
Clinger edited an anthology of new home
stories inspired by the original
characters which had long been in the
public domain uh the doyle estate
threatened to sue Clinger went to court
seeking a declaratory judgment allowing
him to use the holes and Watson
characters from Doyle's public domain
Works in response the estate argued that
a character is a work of authorship that
is not really finished until his
complete character Arc including every
story in which he appeared uh was in the
public domain and since there were 10
Sherlock Holmes stories that were still
under us copyright protection the theory
was that none of the others were in the
public domain the argument would have
given authors a way to maintain control
over the works effectively forever
simply by issuing new works that tweak
the character's traits and then
theoretically the copyright would never
expire under this Theory the public
domain only begins to run when the
author puts down their pen now the
second Circuit Court of Appeals laugh
this out of court affirmed that there is
no such thing as Perpetual copyright but
it's still left open the possibility
that later Sherlock Holmes was a
different character than early Sherlock
Holmes and thus would receive a
different copyright so there's still a
question of is there sufficient
originality in the modern Mickey to
justify a copyright protection and under
American law Disney can only claim
rights for material that represents an
original creative expression for it to
be original it must have at least a
modum of creativity which is why the
Supreme Court in the Feist case once
held that the white pages of a phone
book aren't created enough for copyright
protectionist it's just names and phone
numbers for my younger viewers the White
Pages was a giant public book that uh we
use to look up people's phone numbers to
be able to call them uh yes we lived in
a constant state of being doxed uh I
don't know what to tell you but at the
same time generic character traits are
not protected by copyright law nor are
just trivial additions so common tropes
like robots or spies or samurai or
Cowboys are not copyrightable in and of
themselves you'd have to get a lot more
specific than that and arguably there
aren't that many differences between
steamboat Mickey and modern Mickey his
character is slightly different in how
he acts the early Mickey acted more like
a teenager the 2022 Mickey is more like
a seasoned adult I'm sure many would
argue the changes of Mickey Mouse over
the years represent a huge shift in the
way that he is portrayed and others
would argue that they're trivial and
shouldn't receive independent copyright
protection so to make a complicated
situation even more complicated you have
a lot of different legal issues at play
here one is the copyright ability of the
Steamboat Willie short that's in the
public domain uh the character Mickey
Mouse it might be in the public domain
uh there's probably going to be some
litigation over that then you have
Disney trying to trademark Steamboat
Willie the character for purposes other
than copyright and that's relatively
untested now I've been looking at so
many funny steambow wiie edits on the
internet I'm probably not going to have
time to cook dinner tonight luckily I
have today's sponsor Factor because
Factor makes meeting your nutrition
goals easier than ever by delivering
fresh never Frozen dietition approved
meals right to your door stop and the
meals are completely ready to eat in
Just 2 minutes eliminate the hours it
would take to shop meal prep and cook so
you can spend your day doing the things
that you actually want to do are you too
busy working on your New Year's
resolution but want to make sure that
you're eating well but with Factor you
can skip the extra shft to the grocery
store and all of the shopping prepping
and cleaning up too while still getting
the flavor and nutritional quality that
you need Factory meals arrive
pre-prepared and ready to eat in Just 2
minutes the same amount of time that I
could even think about going to the
grocery store my Factor meal is already
done sometimes I just want a good
healthy meal without having to cook and
it's surprisingly affordable and now
Factor also offers Gourmet plus meals as
part of your weekly options which means
you can get a little gourmet with your
meal plan whenever you're craving
something special gourmet meals like
surf and turf or Surf and surf like
shrimp and salmon uh they're all
delicious and you can relish the best of
spring and winter flavors all their
meals are really extremely delicious
like Bretta shrimp risotto Green Goddess
chicken and grilled steakhous F Minon
ready in Just 2 minutes their menus are
updated weekly with 34 different options
choose your favorite meals or let Factor
craft your order based on your taste
preferences and meal history so give
factor a try by heading to factor75.com
and use the code legal eagle 50 to get
50% off your first Factor box or just
click on the link that's on screen or
down in the description and use the code
legal eagle 50 and get 50% off your
first Factor box after that click on
this box over here for more legal eagle
or I'll see you in court